raiders broncos are the teams to watch
because he wants to be on the west coast
or close to it
the packers don't want him in the nfc
remember what they did with brett favre
in 2008 traded him out of the conference
and if you trade him back to the nfc
north it cost three first round draft
picks and there was one more and i can't
remember what it is but it was a good
one bottom line is
bottom line is raiders broncos 49ers but
the 49ers are off the table now unless
they trade trey lance oh that's the
other thing the packers don't want a
quarterback out of this they didn't want
jimmy g they don't want his 25 million
contract they got jordan love so that's
the other factor i think that makes the
broncos
the favorite unless the raiders are
going to send derek carr somewhere else
but the broncos don't have a quarterback
they're going to send they could send
teddy bridgewater to back up jordan love
but
it's not like there's a starter that's
got to be cleared out a clear-cut
obvious starter that's what makes the
broncos the right fit so afc team west
coaster close to it packers don't want
or need a quarterback in return a
starter in return it all it all points
to the broncos and george payton the gm
of the broncos was asked about it and he
was more he was more careful about what
he said because i think that the broncos
how can they not be in play if you're
the broncos look at what they did with
peyton manning
and peyton manning was a year younger
than aaron rodgers and a lot more banged
up than aaron rodgers when they signed
him in 2012. no i i uh
i'm with you i mean the broncos are a
team that i've heard associated with
rogers for a long time and i really
thought it was going to be more about a
play after the 2021 season that that
they had their eye on rogers but it
makes sense it makes sense for both
sides definitely it does i mean a lot
like you know peyton manning when he
picked the denver broncos broncos are
kind of on the cusp of
maybe being something when you really
break down their football team of course
it's going to be weapons galore when
their wide receiving corp is healthy
it's as talent as there is in football
they got a great tight end they got the
line the offensive line figured out
their defense you know with bradley
chubb and von miller back in full effect
here i mean there's the d lines pretty
damn good the secondary's good they just
got it patrick certain i mean they're
they're a team that's you know on the
cusp of kind of breaking through and
saying watch out we're a real player in
the afc so a guy like rogers would
definitely put them over the hump the
thing that like you know i come back to
is
like
this is where i don't know and maybe it
proves that that last year's first round
pick by the packers was good they can't
they can't trust jordan love
they're gonna go they're gonna trade him
trade rogers and let jordan love be the
starter i gotta see that to believe it i
gotta see it to believe it he was so raw
he had no off season he has had no
preseason play there's no way i would
think even with this even though they
got a jordan love that maybe they'd want
a teddy bridgewater like you're saying a
guy to be that bridge guy just in case
something there for a little bit of an
insurance policy because i don't think
you can just go with jordan love there
so that would be my two cents on that
two two very quick points one if i'm
john schneider packers shareholder and
gm of the seahawks i'm exploring the
possibility of a straight up russell
wilson for aaron rodgers trade yes i am
west coast although it's in the
conference packers probably don't want
to go for it but they would get russell
wilson not a bad transaction yeah if you
can come out of this with russell wilson
secondly secondly
uh the packers yet again did not take a
receiver with their first round pick
georgia cornerback eric stokes with the
29th overall selection he runs fast he
just doesn't play receiver so
more help
or not
for look at that look at that my
goodness
hey uh i i and i i got no problem with
drafting defensive players but the one
thing that's going to stand out forever
for the green bay packers is what they
did last year to get jordan love when
they could have as you said tristan
wurfs antoine winfield what the
buccaneers did a one and a four gone for
a guy who contributed nothing to the
effort to get to the super bowl last
year and it just makes a bad situation
worse for green bay now that it's all
blown up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports